good afternoon or good evening depending
on where you're located from somewhere
around the world welcome and thank you
for joining us
for this webinar with mr tim pearson the
dark web and the need for ethical
hacking
the dark web encompasses that little
known cd or part of the internet and it
can be a villainous kind of
underground web where you can buy and
sell just about anything
it makes up about 70 percent of the
internet you and i on a day-to-day basis
with google we're really only seeing
about 30
of it so today we're going to just take
a little look at what it means inside
this
part of the internet a little about its
relationship to the concept of ethical
hacking and why large organizations
prefer certified ethical hacking pros
who understand the nature of the dark
web
uh we'll be working here today with mr
tim pearson if you're not familiar with
him he is a technical trainer
for the past 27 years one of the world's
leading trainers in
technology networks virtualization and
application security
he has written a number of popular
manuals for global corporations like ec2
count ec council and mile 2
and in addition to teaching of course he
conducts high level security evals
virtualization consulting and delivers
seminars and keynotes
at professional conventions before we
get rolling though
i just want to make sure that you all
are familiar with your dashboard and how
go to webinar works so
tim's going to give his presentation i'm
not sure exactly how long it will run
but let's guess around 30 minutes or so
during the course of the presentation
you can type your questions into the
question module so let's make sure
that's working
why don't you go ahead and type a little
note in there let me know where you're
joining us from what's the weather like
is it beautiful there
are you hiding under a blanket let me
know where you're coming from texas
adam's in texas and says it's
beautiful today i don't doubt that this
is a beautiful time of year in texas
illinois and it's raining well i'm glad
you're inside
uh there michael tennessee and it's warm
fantastic we've got folks from all over
the place and
and thank you for taking the time out of
your day to uh
curl up with us new delhi india
fantastic oh it's uh
it's uh the evening there thank you for
taking time away from your uh
your evening activities and the canadian
rockies wow i love it
all right so that question module that
you're using there that's going to be
your best friend as we are going through
the presentation you go ahead and type
any questions in there you can ask tim
uh you know tough to give a little extra
detail on a point or to go back and
revisit a previous slide
at the end of his presentation and we'll
do that we'll do all the q a
all at once at the end of the
presentation we'll get through as many
questions
as we possibly can if you want to share
what you're learning on social if he
says something super awesome and
insightful which
i'm sure will happen and you want to
share it with your audience go ahead and
live tweet or
post it on linkedin or facebook or what
have you and if you want to you can use
the hashtag
sl webinars
i think that's it you know how the
dashboard works now so
uh we're getting a little bit of a late
start if we need to we'll go a few
minutes late uh
on on our end time to make up for it so
uh tim
my friend it's a pleasure to have you
joining us here i'll turn this
over to you okay then let me get my
microphone a little close to me and
i'm ready to start uh i guess everyone
can see my screen right now
absolutely all right and so let me kind
of give you a little bit of an idea who
i am
my name is tim pearson i'm from dallas
texas uh i
consider myself a researcher and a
consultant i get asked by a lot of
large corporations to come in and
survey their security stands they want
to know what other people can know about
them
uh i was recently interviewed on fox
news
about cloud computing i was the
contributing author to a book
uh vmware vsphere and virtual security
and also been on the cbs national news
in the early show
with uh evidence of wi-fi hacking
and uh we had kind of set up a
a sting operation at a local hotel and
and uh
that's live on youtube if you'd like to
carry search for my name and
wi-fi you probably find it uh i also
want to mention that i was timed person
of the year in 2006
and if you know much about that
in reality so were you so
time named the person of the year uh you
and so i was the person of the year and
actually so were you so as we move
forward here
okay so it's not telling me
when i needed to be told it is it okay
so as we move forward here uh
there are only two types of companies
that have been hacked
those that have been hacked and those
that will be hacked
what we need to understand is that
we will be hacked what we need to
understand
is what will be the thing we need to do
after we've been attacked
nobody really has that plan b they all
they all have
plan a which basically says i am
only going to uh work on the premise
that
i am not going to be attacked not
necessarily that they ever would be
attacked
but really we need to have that plan b
i guess probably the most uh
interesting situation was uh and the way
i
kind of justify what i do is i was asked
by my mom
who's about 86 years old right now she
know what i chose i teach something with
computers but doesn't know exactly what
i teach
uh i told her uh i'm basically teaching
people how to hack into computers
and i got the response you'd expect from
an 86 year old woman
good god what are you doing that for my
answer to her was
how could you possibly understand how to
protect your home
unless the first the burglar shows you
unless we first show you how the burglar
was gonna break into it
and when you think about it yeah that's
true
that's absolutely true and that's the
premise behind
the whole reason we teach the world to
hack for good
because we have to understand how we're
going to be attacked
in order for us to possibly stop it from
happening
we go on to the next slide here
i get this to move here uh
the average individual consumes
consumer uh carries about 25
uh less than 60 under 25 carries about
60 in cash
the rest they actually uh
use with credit cards uh near field
communication
which simply means that i take my credit
card and hold it near
a pay terminal is going to be over 130
billion by 2020.
so the possibility of me being able to
or someone being able to intercept my
data and charge things in my card
is very prevalent this confidence
actually is going to affect a lot of
people
so if i take the regulations and
compliance
that doesn't seem to be really a whole
lot of oversight
so we have to do a lot of that ourselves
take ashley madison for example
i'm so i'm sure a lot of people have
heard about ashley madison and it was in
the news a couple of years ago
where uh they advertised uh life is too
short to go ahead and have an affair
and naturally when their
system was hacked they released a lot of
these
well they released all the information
uh to the world
and people that actually had paid ashley
madison to be taken
off of their list because they may have
had a moment of indiscretion
at some point in time were actually
still on there so they accepted the
money
but never really took them off the list
so
it's it really gets to the point of who
do you trust
and really the the thing that i can tell
you is
the only person you're really going to
be able to trust is yourself
so you're going to have to take things
into your own hands
where you're going to
need to understand how things work and
how you can be hacked
and try and protect yourself so if you
look at the evolution of finance for
example in 1970s
we're in the local community then we
move into the 80s where we have branches
where
credit checks are done and that kind of
thing uh then moving on to online
uh day trading uh in the 1990s that was
really popular
uh to make money then moving into
uh the new millennium the change starts
to begin
where now we have things where
we can pay almost immediately near field
communications
emv apple pay uh a paypal
all of these things uh release
amount of metadata of what we're doing
all right
so here in 2015 2016
we're in where this change is actually
beginning
so the hackers it's really
hard to believe how fast the world is
changing
if you look at uh tesla as a as an
example where
the autonomous vehicle is actually
starting to drive itself
uh kind of scary in a lot of ways
all of these individuals right here
were pieces of things that have been
hacked
now we're talking about things that we
know about
but let's dive in and that's scary
enough but let's dive in a little bit
deeper
if i dive in to what's known as the dark
web
where hackers are actually buying and
selling data
the dark net and the dark web is used
i'm going to explain what that is here
in just a second
malware markets used by hackers to buy
this software so you could pay
individuals that don't have a lot of
ethics per se
uh into buying and selling this
particular
software that grabs the information
uh money laundering uh ghost markets
bitcoins bitcoin is very popular because
there's no tracking it
then we have fraud and counterfeit loss
of property all of these things
can be part of the dark net now
let's take a look at the levels of an
argument the first level is what we
refer to as the common web
all right that's really level zero
that's where we are right now
uh we typically uh go into
level zero level one which is surface
web where
we get reporting from things like reddit
dig
uh temporary email services all that
kind of thing
level two is where it starts to get a
little bit uh mystified
all right uh the bergie whip google lock
results honey pops
uh news groups uh ftp services things of
that nature
then we move into level four which is
the uh the charter web
hacking groups uh uh shelly networks uh
artificial intelligence theorists
banned media activist communications all
of these types of things
are what we call a level four of the
dark web
level five is the big level uh what we
consider to be the dark web
now at level five we have what we refer
to as onion sites
now let me explain to you what an onion
site is there is a
a utility called tor it stands for the
onion router
and it's like bits of an onion where we
peel back layers of that onion
to get access to material
where they would know who we are
and you can buy this illegal material uh
possibly human trafficking bounty
hunters
rare animal trade different types of
exploits
black markets drugs all of those types
of things are available on the dark web
i think this next slide will actually
be kind of interesting to you what we
typically see
is the visible web that's what you're
going to get from google
that's what you're going to get from the
communications
at google the deep web or the hidden net
is like an iceberg where you only see
the very top of it
but underneath there's a whole lot more
than actually we could see
as i talked about earlier you could
download
uh this piece of software or you could
download an entire
operating system that's built with this
piece of software which is typically the
the best way of doing this and you
would get access to sites
that are referred to as onion sites all
right and you can see
i just did a google search for tor
hidden wiki
uh normally they start with dot onion
the urls
sometimes you can get access to this
normally you have to be almost invited
in to this realm of piracy if you would
moving further in here here's some
things that
have been easily seen that you can buy
for example if you wanted to buy fifty
dollar u.s uh bills
okay they're produced on regular cotton
paper the same thing
that the us treasury produces they pass
the pen test you know where
you've seen when you hand a teller or
anyone who's taking your money a bill
and they'll take a marker and they'll
mark on the bill and
it'll turn purple if it's uh counterfeit
if it's not on this cotton-based paper
but it will just stay yellow if it's not
and they pass this test
you know uvi is incorporated so it
passes that test as well
they actually have been used
and we sent these as a test
we sent these into i believe it was
20 banks european banks and
only one caught the bills and these were
actually at banks themselves
so it'd be very very difficult to detect
this
all right and we had the permission from
the banks to do this we wanted to see
how easy it was to detect something like
this
things like paypal accounts now why
would you ever want
to buy someone's paypal account well
paypal accounts
that has a hundred dollars on it are
worth uh uh about 26
uh bitcoin okay which is at the time of
this uh
writing was less than a hundred dollars
about uh maybe
twenty dollars so you're buying a
hundred dollars for twenty dollars
all right well yeah i could see where
that might be advantageous but
uh they're actually buying this so they
could purchase
services on the internet they will be
actually drawn back to someone else
100 ebay accounts where you're sent
material
okay by just changing who it's sent to
an intermediary who ships it off to
someone else
a hundred credit card numbers with the
cv2 numbers on them
okay credit card numbers are actually uh
not very expensive at all
uh because they can be turned off
instantly
but uh someone's identity which is also
sold here with a credit with their
social security number their full legal
name
and their uh uh location or their full
legal address
are three things that are needed to
steal someone's identity
very very easily done
let's look at some things that might be
done here's
an example of our paypal center uh
the various balances and the price
they're offering for these so here's one
for
700 okay uh their price is 85
and you can buy this add it to your cart
and would it have 700
in that account when you got to it maybe
it would maybe have more
maybe it would have less but they've
just simply stolen the credentials
from this individual and more than
likely this would be
done to harness
evil deeds let's see what kind of
other things that i could do uh
let's just go ahead and see if i can uh
i'll pull up one live if i possibly can
here
i'm going to show you one of the most
powerful hacking tools on the internet
right now i'm not sure why this square
is here uh
i'm going to type in site colon paste
bin dot com and what that means is
in google i'm going to allocate
uh everything i search for uh has to be
as part of pastebin.com and i'm going to
type in maybe mastercard
okay it has to have the word mastercard
in there
and you can see that uh we've got
a number of places and i'm going to look
at google's
cached account where i can find
uh stolen credit card numbers exactly
what i've seen
before now uh am i really
concerned about showing you this not
really because more than likely these
credit cards have already been turned
off
uh i wanted to show you how easy it was
for the
the individual to be able to get access
to this information
so we're send them a code from
pastebin but they don't necessarily
erase that from baseband and google
indexes
so this is part of our
issue part of our problem i could uh
find a number of different things on
here let's let's see if we can try and
find something else
okay uh let's let's just look for
someone
uh social security number and
unfortunately uh you can see very easily
that this person i won't put his name up
here well exactly there is his name
his date of birth social security number
these things are readily
and easily available on the internet
that person
that you just saw one here is
unfortunately in
uh had his credit stolen okay because
it's very easy
for somebody to do something like that
now the black market on the dark web
they change
these various addresses okay often
and you really have to be invited by
someone to get into this
and most people think that the dark web
as well it's just about buying drugs
well that is part of it all right but uh
there's a lot more to it than that
there's uh
different types of con artists that can
be purchased crime guns
even people as you're going to see here
in just a couple of moments
here some various uh
goods whether these were stolen from
louis vuitton
or whether they were legitimately
purchased
more than likely this is something
stolen off of uh
one of their stores or trucks something
like that they're buying it
uh for one point uh whatever bitcoin and
you'd have to figure out exactly
you know what that's worth it's
definitely gonna be worth a lot more
or excuse me a lot less than you would
pay for it at louis vuitton
some social engineering skills that are
uh
often fine you can hire somebody to do
virtually anything
all right so this person says that uh i
have very good written spoken
english and german if i can't hack
something
technically i'll make phone calls or
write emails to the target
to get the information needed i've had
people make things uh
you wouldn't really often believe a lot
of experience with security practices
big
insider corporations uh a friend of mine
had done this one 60 minutes where
he changed his phone number which is
easily done
uh to reflect that they were calling
from inside
uh the corporation called the
corporation's help desk
and said i'm trying to get to this
website and i'm
for some reason there's it's not working
correctly and i've got this project that
i've got to do could you help me get
there any
named the website the person at the help
desk who generally has a lot of uh
information or a lot of escalated
security
can go in and get access to this
they were then able to just click on
something
and they gave them access to the inside
of that corporate network very easily
done
this person right here says i'll do
anything for money i'm not
and the word i'm sure that was
put out there he's not some kind of a
escort service or whatever
if you want me to destroy someone's
business or a person's life i'll do it
some examples might be simply hacking
something technically
causing a lot of technical trouble on
websites uh network uh
disruptive services with ddos getting
private information from someone
actually ruining your opponents business
or private persons you don't even like i
can ruin them financially
get them arrested uh have them
change their information where they're
on the child
porn list no problem at all and here's
their rates for doing it
it's it's really quite amazing
let's talk about stealing your credit
card just as an example
okay a victim would be easily
uh not safe from a
chip and pin if you were able to grab
that chip and pin
from some kind of a skimmer device
financial experts
actually are able to
actually see the starter package of 50
credits they cost about 59
sending a message cost like five credits
and replies are free
if a message is marked priority the site
deducts an additional five credits
uh basically what they're doing right
here is is they are
giving you the information from a
skimmer that they have attached
to an atm machine you've seen these in
bars you've seen these in
hotel rooms or hotel lobbies things that
look like they're part of the
part of the machine but they're really
not
you can buy
from this place called skimmer
manufacturer and
here's the software and the various
bezels and that type of stuff to make
the machine
look like it's legitimate
show you how to be careful
when you're using these types of
machines street atms gas stations rkh
hotels
i'm going to say probably the safest
atms are going to be at a bank
if you try and use the atm at
some of these other places i've named
right here it's possible that you could
have your card skinned
meaning that they've grabbed your card
details and they've grabbed your pin
number
where all of your information could be
actually taken
and all your money out of your account
and if you know your pin details
there's a lot of countries that are not
going to put that money back in
so here is kind of the fight against
cyber crime
you have your bank account credentials
and data
digital real estate all these are
victims
okay and we have criminal organizations
and their affiliates
a lot of partnerships okay crimeware
producers
being able to create uh this type of
crime
uh kind of tell you a real quick story
my wife is a
a professional photographer and she uses
a mac
because according to her the macs aren't
vulnerable to
hackers which i've i've tried to tell
her it's it's not in use
okay uh she got a pop-up on her
screen that said you have a virus would
you like us to clean it
well she cleaned it and uh locked up all
of the photos that she'd been working
well over 200 hours on on on
photoshop of a wedding that she had just
taken the pictures for now if you think
about it
uh she had a lot of money invested but
if they didn't we didn't pay the
ransomware
for this which at that time was about
200 and something dollars
uh i looked at the encryption it was
encrypted with 256-bit aes
now my wife not knowing too much about
how the encryption works
basically went back to the bride and
groups don't worry don't worry
my husband a professional computer
hacker he can get it back
i talked to her and pulled her aside i
said no i can't i don't know where
you're getting that from
so what did i do i had to pay the
ransomware it was either that
or not give this couple their
photos which really wasn't an option
and that it was my wife said well they
said they were good they were going to
clean
my computer and i said didn't you
believe them these are the types of
things that
we're up against things that we have to
raise our awareness of
and to do that
is to be able to be aware of these
things so you can
keep it or at least be aware of them
moving in to some of the players on the
dark web
we have of course organized crime it can
be established like smash and grab where
we
where we have things like tj maxx and
target where they
grab many many credit cards but keep in
mind
the credit cards aren't going to be a
big problem because
i can turn those off in two seconds
and so really that's not worth a
tremendous amount of money
if you uh see on the black market a
credit card
a stolen credit card is worth
approximately
uh maybe i think a dollar
okay uh although
if uh it may be less than that now maybe
20 cents
uh a person's personal identity
that means their full legal name their
social security number their date of
birth
full legal address those kinds of
information that's worth about ten
dollars on the black market
now if you do just a little bit of math
if i go into and let's just pick on some
u.s corporation uh
and i'm just randomly uh mentioning so
let's say 3m corporation or
or let's say uh ibm whoever it would
might happen to be
that has a large amount of
employees and you're able to get into
their hr department
in their hr department they're gonna
have to pay payment details
for all of those pieces of information
that i just mentioned
so if that company has a hundred
thousand employees
i guarantee you you just made yourself a
millionaire
that's what they're typically after
they're typically after
these large organizations stealing the
information about the individuals the
most
uh information that is the most
prevalent
are the information for the agent and
you might think well
what they usually don't have that much
money yes that's true
but the way that medicare works it's
very
easy to scam medicare and get
information and get the money from
medicare
and the individuals from anywhere from
21 to about 40 years old
maybe up to 50 years old those are prime
targets for
uh identity theft because they generally
have
not generally mostly they'll have good
credit and we can steal that credit
all right there are ways of locking down
that credit uh in the u.s and
i'll talk about that that's kind of as i
answer some questions
but so the smash and grab techniques of
just grabbing the credit cards
it's really not that impressive
although if they were to grab that hr
information then
that's going to be quite a little bit
more all right
the average exploit when someone gets
into a company before they're noticed
is approximately if i remember correctly
it's 135 days
so most of these times most of the time
it could be you know close to a half a
year some some uh
some people say it's all the way up to
more or even more than a year
there was somebody that got into jp
morgan uh chase and and they actually
were there for
uh several years
and then naturally uh ransom
okay and some of the popular ones i've
given you one of them was ransomware
uh sony pictures was kind of held for
ransom by the uh
north korean they decided not to release
that picture because it embarrassed
them ashley madison another one tonight
i gave you an example of
so who are the players in this
generally a lot of them are former
soviet military
the russian mafia professional hackers
possibly spammers trying to get you to
click on something
traditional mafia basic cyber crime
organizations there's a lot of really
bad people in the world
that we're trying to protect ourselves
against let's take the first one
the uh uh former soviet union
military there's a lot of military
industrial complex in
soviet russia that was much more corrupt
than their usa counterparts with the
collapse of communism
uh many upper military personnel inside
of russia themselves
they had few skills that paid well so
they were good
you know good at money laundering we're
good at moving goods across borders
and we have a lot of connection with
international crime
who is going to buy that skill set
well i think you've already figured out
who's going to buy that skill set
so we have a lot of individuals
that maybe want to feed their family and
i'm not
trying to victimize these people because
they are doing evil deeds
but they want to get paid the most and
money is a great enticement
then we have places like the russian
mafia uh one of the head of the russian
mafia
i'm not going to try and pronounce his
name sergey uh head of the moscow
uh based russian mafia organization has
over 5000 members worldwide
he started with extortion uh
counterfeiting drug
drug trafficking blackmail arms dealing
you know anything that you could think
of
uh he owns his own organization it was a
banks casinos car dealerships
and even an airport very difficult to
stop
something like this and you've heard a
lot about the russian mafia
the second largest gang operating out of
russia is uh
this one i'm not going to try and
pronounce that name either cyber crimes
and activities a lot of the
standard criminal ventures they believe
behind a rash of bank robberies uh
conducted over the internet in 2001
especially against banks using
vulnerable windows nt
web servers oftentimes
it's people are slow to move off their
technology because it's working
let's take a look at some of the things
that we could purchase
all right here's some of the uh
a form that is on this particular uh web
form
okay where they're asking various
questions uh in a chat group
uh this one is called dark prophets okay
and they're asking uh various
discussions where you could
ask these types of information that kind
of stuff
okay and uh this right here represents
the amount of tor
traffic now let's uh
take for example tor and what it does
is it basically starts by hopping
through
uh many different nodes
on the internet if you were to take a
look at
your home router i'm just going to use
the illustration of the little blue
linksys router that we may have
uh it uses something called nat or
network address translation
what it does is it translates a private
address the 10.x
addresses the 192.68 addresses the
172.16 addresses
into a public ip address on the internet
but what if we took that nat router and
put it into
another nat router and took that other
nat
router and plumbed it into another nat
router and
went on for maybe 20 or 30 nat routers
all right finding how to get back to the
original one
where the tables are erased
for example the logs are raised perhaps
daily that gives you a little bit of an
idea of tor
but tor also encrypts the message as it
hops
from one person to the other so the
entrance node in tor sees the
full text data as clear text and the
exit node before it goes to the ultimate
recipient sees it
but all of the torah routers in between
it see only the encrypted data
and so the the us government
and several governments are all all
looking for
exit nodes and they're looking to see
what kind of information
is coming out these exit nodes because
if you're going to go
through the trouble of having your
traffic encrypted with torque
that's a good possibility you're not
doing something that's necessarily
up and up and i would say that's
probably true
i have a friend of mine that works for
the nsa and they
they he tells me that that's primarily
what they look for
is tour traffic all right so if you're
wanting to fly under the radar tor may
not be the best way
of of determining that
okay so moving on
let's start with the why people would
even
do this well first off
in let's say back in the bonnie and
clyde days where
we want to go rob a bank there's a high
chance of us getting caught
there's people with guns at the bank
there are individuals
uh at the bank that uh possibly uh
uh could cause us some problems let me
go back to this one slide real quick
there we go that's what i wanted to say
at so what we need to look at what the
motive is of hackers
if you start with why risk going to jail
we actually have
a maybe one in 99
chance of getting caught
and then of that one and 99 chance of
getting caught
we actually have maybe a 1 in 100 chance
of actually getting prosecuted for it
do the individuals that are going to rob
the bank the bonnie and clyde that i had
talked about earlier do they have that
same
level of risk their risk is much greater
all right this is why it's
very motive it's it's the big motive of
of
attackers you could easily damage
somebody's reputation
uh getting paid with money humiliation
they have a lot of calls and they can
profit off somebody's pain
for example they profited off the pain
that my wife had
you know when when they had stole or
they had locked up they had
actually didn't steal it the pictures
all right
they used something called uh ransomware
and ransomware
now comes in what's referred to as
a
what's referred to as a like for
example.net is a library of sorts or is
a uh
a framework of sorts they have a
framework of sorts
that they can use for ransomware
making it very easy very trivial for
someone to get into the ransomware
business
and steal your information as a matter
of fact
i've read articles where individuals are
being asked to work for these companies
and they
they'll pay your child care they'll pay
for uh benefits they pay medical they
pay retirement
i mean this is big business because if
you are
sitting in a company that actually
tries to do this and in the country i
should say
it's actually trying to do this the
chances of you getting caught
or even getting prosecuted are slim to
none
and the way they the individuals justify
it why can't we take
some of the west's money when
my gosh they have so much me we're just
simply trying to feed our family
i'm not saying it's right and i'm not
saying it's wrong i'm just saying that's
the kind of thing that we have to deal
with uh
the internet is can be a very bad place
and we have a lot of issues with that
okay so how the uh how
is called the journey that is the kill
chain okay
so we're going to start out with the
impact and
severity and the phases of that kill
chain
first off we're going to start out with
reconnaissance all right
this is our our simple lowest impact of
security
when i do a pin test on your
organization
i'm going to see all the different ways
that i could attack you
without ever touching your organization
i'm going to look at google i'm going to
look at
the various places that have the
metadata and i'll never go to your
organization
but i will look up on linkedin who the
people that i could target
who are the one individuals in your
organization that i could surveil
that i could possibly uh extort
you know i'm gonna look where the
low-hanging fruit
might be okay then we'll move into
uh weaponization all right so
i'm going to actually try and weaponize
some of those
targets that i may have identified in
this recon phase
uh ideal weapon crafted to build buy or
rent
a bot for example how many people have
heard the story especially like from
their parents or somebody because
everyone in this
particular session right here i can
guarantee you you are
the i.t department for your family and
if you know much about
computers you are that i.t department
and you've heard
your family basically what why in the
world would they want anything i have i
don't keep anything on my computer
they don't necessarily want what you
have on your computer
they want your computer they want to
make it into a weapon that they can use
to take down a lot of opponents and
maybe perhaps point the crime back to
you
uh they can also crypto cryptify their
service cryptifies that a word i think
it is
they can encrypt their service and
remain very very stealthy in doing that
the delivery might be
uh the delivery of this weapon against
the target maybe it's
email uh phishing social media a usb
websites there's a lot of those things
that we cover
in some of these classes that that
most of the people that go through a
class that i teach
i've heard they will they're not going
to touch the computer for for years
after that
a little impractical but the class does
really scare you
exploitation is the portion where we
actually break in
to your computer the code triggers an
installation
uh and then we have some kind of
persistence mechanism uh the persistence
mechanism is
is how even if you reboot the machine it
still reinstalls the bot
it still redoes what we're trying to do
and then the highest action
where we compose data and commands ex
exchanged over a a second communication
channel
uh the objective is achieved data excel
exfiltrated
uh intrusion of the second stage uh
target all those kinds of things are
done
so why are you thinking of what to walk
while you're thinking of what you're
going to watch on tv tonight
24 years of organized crime was a
different on a different
journey with your data maybe you were
looking uh
of things when your cable box maybe you
were uh
surfing the web looking for this a lot
of that information
can easily be tracked
on financial impacts uh we have
three trillion u.s dollars that have
been stolen from
uh the the information that can be
gathered from class hash law class acts
and
lawsuits ipo impact okay initial public
offering
bad press or losses all of these things
can be
can have occurred because of someone
stealing that information
and and making you look bad embarrassing
your corporation
all right most people after the the big
target
heist of all the credit cards i was not
i had no problem
shopping at target after that because i
know that i'm protected
on my credit card i mean for example if
my credit card was stolen at target
i'd call my credit card company i would
get my money back
most people still uh didn't want to shop
at target because of this
huge loss of credit card data now
i would be very concerned if someone
hacked into an organization that had my
social security number that had uh
my a lot of very pertinent information
okay the bigger you are actually the
more
i want to use the word easy it's not
necessarily easy the more uh
subjective you subjected you are to
getting this information uh let's just
take a couple of
information here 101 espn employees
uh there's a dead spin report
that they were actually uh
they were actually uh forced into uh
divorce wedding cancellation a lot of
things because
information that they had might come out
loss of research
intellectual data identity theft
scammers uh
those kinds of things basic economic
disaster okay loss of business uh
or even non-recoverable consequences
that you can't even recover from
this one i think will really kind of
be interesting for you uh this
is a uh a credit report now let me tell
you how dangerous
this is and i'm gonna tell you right now
you never ever never ever ever never did
i say never
i hope i said never ever put your credit
report and save it to a pdf or anything
else and keep it on your computer
because if the bad guys happen to get
your credit report there is not a
question
that they cannot answer if somebody
asks them questions pertaining
to your information haven't you ever
been asked by a bank
did you ever live at this particular
address did you ever get a loan from
this particular company
did you ever do business with this
company did you ever have a credit card
from this company
where do you think they're getting the
information to ask you those questions
if you guessed your credit report then
you're exactly correct
if that credit report would fall into
someone else's hands
i'm sorry but it's game over so
don't ever store your credit report
on your computer sure download your
credit report print your credit report
off
uh print uh put it into a folder and put
it in your
drawer in your desk that's fine make
sure that you delete the credit report
from the computer
so we're going to want to look
for actionable threat intelligence all
right
try to mitigate that threat before they
enter your network
this is the proactive phase all right
and possibly
if we do discover it uh discover the
threats that entered or tried to enter
the network
and then three you know basically
respond to it
okay as if it has been breached
all right on an instant response so let
me go ahead and move right on to
uh some questions that i might have so
if i can get the announcer to uh
come back online and and asking some of
the questions that would be
great absolutely tim
uh thank you uh so much for that it's i
really
personally had no insight into what the
dark web was all about i've heard it
mentioned but i didn't realize how
how pervasive and how dark it can truly
be
fascinating stuff there are some
questions queued up before we do that
really quickly i'm going to ask
everybody to
bear with me for a second while i take
care of some simply learn business
which means i'm going to take over the
screen here real quick
and launch this very simple little poll
here
uh what's what that's about is uh
obviously this webinar is the public
facing webinar that means that there's
some folks on here with us today who
uh maybe have never heard of simply
learn outside of these webinars you're
not familiar with us and what we do
and and you found out about this webinar
through a link on social or maybe a
friend
sent you here and that's fine we're
happy to have you here and thanks for
joining us we run
a lot of these webinars every month and
we talk
about a lot of different kinds of topics
so clearly
ethical hacking and security issues we
talk about
project management and so forth and
beyond that though
what we do as our core service is that
we're a business and technology training
provider
we offer 400 web-based training courses
and if you're interested in taking
courses and learning more about
ethical hacking and how to turn that
into a career for yourself by keeping
companies
and individuals safe tick the
appropriate box we'll have someone get
in touch with you
and they can help you choose the right
course of training to
make the most out of your career uh in
ethical hacking
i am being told by my uh
oh a lock is having to leave us uh
thanks again for being here a lot and uh
sorry you can't stay
a little longer sorry we got a bit of a
late start but uh
we are going to go ahead and get to the
questions here in just a moment for the
rest of you who are able to stick with
us
so go ahead and take the appropriate box
we'll have somebody get in touch with
you no obligation
but uh happy to tell you a little more
about that i'll also be sharing a link
over to the simply learn site guiding
you to
some of information on our ethical
hacking courses so i'm going to close
this now and we should be going
back to tim's screen there we go so tim
just so you know we're seeing your
screen again
if you decide you need to surf around or
anything to answer any of these
questions
so we have a few questions queued up i'm
going to take care of the very first one
myself because it's a very common
question and the question is is this
being recorded
and or can i get access to the slide
deck and the answer is yes
all of our webinars are recorded uh but
uh
they are gone through they go through a
little production process we clean them
up a little bit and then they get posted
to
the simply learn site and they also very
often end up on our
youtube channel so if you're not
subscribed over there yet please do so
and then you'll get a notification when
new videos
go up uh let's see
here in terms of questions tim this one
came up for a few folks
what is the best third
party kind of anti-virus or
anti-hacking kind of software that we
can
get access to on the open market install
on the laptops for our company or for
ourselves personally
that will give us some reasonable amount
of
um of security against this sort of
thing is you know things
we hear about things like malwarebytes
or microsoft security essentials where
should we go
yeah and that's that's a that's a great
question
let me answer the question by telling
you just a real quick little story
as of anywhere from 2001
uh to about 2014 antivirus
uh manufacturers had found
in the order of about 300 and 300
thousand two hundred fifty thousand
three hundred thousand
uh virus signatures a year
as 2015 and 2016 rolled around
the antivirus manufacturers started
seeing a tremendous
uptick but we're seeing 300 000
to 350 000 signatures
a day let me repeat that a day
there is no way that an anti-virus
organization could possibly give you
all of the signatures to flag the virus
so am i talking gloom and doom
not really i'm hoping that you're you're
not perceiving this as gloom and dude
but i do want you to understand that
the answer that i give you is my
personal preference i would go
with the microsoft answer
because one one reason it's free
another reason uh uh is
you're not gonna be able to find
everything there's there's no way
am i touting that you shouldn't use
antivirus no
i'm not saying that uh especially if
you're
a person that isn't is easily fooled
myself do i use antivirus no i don't it
slows my computer down
and i feel like the if
if i was able to get a virus i i would
notice it but pretty readily
i have the various mechanisms where
my computer is rebuilt every single day
i do all of my surfing uh from
a uh a virtual machine that's rebuilt
every day
so if somebody did get a hold of my
machine it would last for a decade
uh that does take quite a bit of doing
it and
you might uh say that i'm very paranoid
person well
okay i i i agree with that but
uh the short answer is if i had to go
with one i think i would go with
microsoft security essentials
but i didn't feel obliged to tell you
that you know there's not a tremendous
amount of protection there
if somebody really wants to get in
they're gonna get in
that's really all there is to it you
need to be thinking about
what you're going to do once they do get
in
interesting so having that uh
particularly for a corporation having
having that uh response plan in place
uh to uh to shut things down quickly and
to rebuild uh and and secure your and
your customers
materials as quickly as possible that
makes good
sense
i should also mention that another thing
people should be doing
is encrypting their computers encrypting
them
with uh the microsoft encryption that
comes with microsoft
uh uh bitlocker uh for example
uh if you
and your corporation are attached to
a uh active directory
and you have administrative privileges
on your own machine
i can be in your corporate i can have
total control over your entire active
directory in less than five minutes
if your machine is encrypted i can't do
that
and i'm talking i'm not talking about
laptops that you take out of the office
i'm talking about the machines
themselves
that are part of your corporate network
they should all be encrypted
good to know good to know and that's and
that's uh if you're using microsoft
that's baked in there as an option
that's correct that's correct and i'll
go over this in in my class i'll go into
a great amount of detail and i'll show
you
exactly how they would get in and in
less than five minutes i'll be in
good fantastic good to know um
samir has a comment is it true that some
of these antivirus companies that that
offer
you know downloadable free or uh paid
uh antivirus softwares that they
actually support the creation and
release of new viruses to help their
business is that
really part of the business model in
that industry well let me tell you what
he's talking about here
let me uh uh back up and i'm
picking up
uh a site uh that uh
that i can go to uh
virustotal.com is one of the sites that
he's talking about
uh this is a free service where you
could
upload a uh i'm not sure if my screen is
being shown or not
but uh uh you can just yes we're seeing
your screen okay
you can upload a uh an
exe an executable and it will be scanned
by a number
of anti-virus manufacturers virustotal
is actually the best one
but there's another one that i typically
use in class
because it kind of lists the antivirus
manufacturers on it these are the
would it be nice if there was somebody
that would scan it by
uh every single one of these that would
be nice wouldn't it
all right well by uploading your file to
jotty or virus totally
does just that but what he's talking
about is it is a double-edged sword
because the the uh the bad guys
will prove that none of these anti-virus
manufacturers can catch
what they have done to uh to conceal
their virus but by doing that
you are actually uh giving the antivirus
manufacturers uh a reason to look more
closely at that and and
possibly find it so that is absolutely
true
okay it's kind of a double-edged sword
there isn't it
yeah that's uh it almost feels like a
losing battle
in a way you know it's just it's never
going to end it's a it's a tide that
we can't hold back i've had people that
have taken my class and at the end of
the class uh i had this one guy not too
long ago took out of it
shook my hand he said fantastic class i
hate you
nobody else is nobody else is going to
fix this stuff i'm the only person
now how am i going to fix it well
wouldn't you rather know
than not know i guess ignorance is bliss
oh my goodness uh my um
my mother-in-law is in her 70s and she
recently fell for one of these you've
got a virus let me clean it scams she
has a very hard time as an elderly user
telling the difference between what's an
ad
on a site and what's part of the actual
navigation and she was in yahoo and she
saw something that
clearly represented itself as yahoo i.t
support
clicked on it ended up on a phone call
guy says hey i can see you've got a
some kind of virus on your machine why
don't you let me in real quick and i'll
scan your machine
she gave him access to her laptop he
says oh
yeah oh you've got all kinds of stuff in
here oh you got to let me fix it
yeah yeah wow it's so easy for them to
do
i want to jump through a few more of
these questions really quick here adam
says he runs a couple of commercial
sorry e-commerce sites where do i start
learning
to make the most uh benefit for my sites
what particular area
of i.t security should i first start
with
to start educating myself about how to
protect uh
protect my sites come to my class i mean
i i i'm not i'm trying to i'm not saying
it as an advertisement
i'm saying that as the ultimate truth
because we will talk about all
of the different ways you could be
attacked and they're going to be
greater for some organizations than they
are for others and so
i can't really give him a a cut and
dried answer because
after coming to the class then
i can address any question that you have
that's absolutely reasonable actually
folks for those of you that are still on
with us
i just put some links into the chat
module for everybody to see
so one of them is a link to the simply
learn site guiding you to where
the ethical hacking courses are and from
there of course you can surf around and
see a lot of other courses available to
you too but that'll shortcut you
in the right direction to get rolling um
the
i also gave you a link to some other
resources articles and ebooks and things
that we have up on the site regarding
uh this issue and then of course a link
to uh
to be able to surf around see any other
upcoming webinars in
a number of other specialties uh
including and outside of uh
these security uh challenges so uh
i hope that at least starts to answer
your question adam and and by the way
adam says tim you are the man he
appreciates you
hosting this real quickly here
let's see does the in-house ethical
hacking training
prepare you sufficiently to appear for
the ceh exam and i think i can answer
that question
which is yes and take a look at those
links that i've sent you to and you will
see
that they uh courses are are based to
address the latest bach
uh for uh book of knowledge for a ceh
and should prepare you sufficiently for
the exam um
absolutely we've let's see we've already
answered samir's question
i want to get through one or two more
before we have to take off
um
what are the prerequisites for attending
the ethical hacking course what what
should somebody's uh
technical expertise and experience be to
get the most out of it that's a great
question that's a great question
uh you're going to need to be proficient
at general computer skills if you've had
like the security plus
or you've had or you've been using a
computer in a technical
sense like as a help desk or as a
systems administrator for a number of
years those are going to be the people
that get the most
good out of the class somebody who like
you
mentioned your mother she would not be a
good person because she would not
understand all the stuff that we're
talking about
you know a lot of prerequisites that
would need to be
uh done first before they actually
understand
okay and then i can even offer a test uh
that's like 50 questions
uh to give you a little bit of feedback
if you'd like to take it to see if
you're interested if this class will be
uh good for you
perfect i appreciate that uh let's see
uh we've got time maybe for
for for one more uh tamesh has a
question uh he's working on an
application for a banking application
how can i make sure that my application
is safe that i'm building i think maybe
we can expand that
question uh and and wrap somebody else's
inquiry into it too which is
uh if i'm working as an ethical hacker
what are our personal security
responsibilities
when we're accessing client data uh not
only with respect to things like
people's personal info but things like
hipaa and other federal regulations are
we going to learn about
how to be conscientious of those sorts
of things
and the answer is yes you will now the
the
your first class is uh uh i
like for example the ethical hacking
classes is kind of more about
these are the tools that are in your
toolbox all right just like a plumber
has a set of tools
a carpenter has his set of tools a
hacker whether he be ethical or
unethical has his set of tools
it's more about the tools that are in
your toolbox
now there will be a follow-on course
which is actually penetration testing
where you go in hack the person's site
with their permission
for the good of that person that would
be the answer to the person who is
asking
i'm developing a banking application how
do i know that i'm
del going down the right track the best
way to know
is to have someone other than yourself
try and break into it
all right and hire an individual uh
corporations should not be accepting
applications written from an outside
source without them being pin tested
first
because there are a lot of developers
and i teach a development course
that basically uh it's it's very similar
to hacking your own
uh developed website before somebody
else does so we teach the developers how
to hack
all right and and what they would be
subjected to
all right and there's a lot of learning
that goes on in that and
they end up coding in a completely
different fashion
that's perfect thank you for that um
lots lots of things for folks to think
about with regard to keeping themselves
safe we're going to get one more
question in and then we are going to
have to scoop
and this is kind of a this this fella
says i know this isn't exactly business
related per se
but with regard to the passwords that we
use either personally
or at work to access uh particular
applications or services
i hear that it's best obviously to use a
different password for every account
change them often
but i also hear from some people that
it's more secure and harder to hack
passwords that are random word
combinations like unicorn bobsled
than it is to to hack a letter number
string like one two three abc
can you eliminate on the best way to go
for
choosing passwords and i can tell you uh
of a free utility called lastpass
that will generate a a random string of
characters
uh and it will be different for every
site that you go to
mine are generally 40 characters long
and they're different for every site
most people will tell me how do you
possibly remember it i don't remember it
my the application remembers it but i
use
one passphrase to get into that
digest if you will or encrypted storage
then it puts it in for me automatically
and that blob of data is replicated
around
the internet to all of my devices like
uh my iphone
my ipad uh the browser on my mac the
browser on my
a windows machine but the blob of data
is never given the password so no one
could actually decrypt it
so even if the nsa held a gun to the guy
at last passed his head
and said give me the the password he
couldn't do it all right he could give
you the blob of encrypted data
that is aes 256 bit encrypted which
uh to give you uh an idea how strong
that is
if we had a computer that could decrypt
our second strongest which is triple des
in one second it would take that same
machine
149 trillion years to crack
aes at only 128 bits
so our scientists have actually
predicted our universe is
about uh our sun is
i think about 5 billion years old and
whether or something's going to burn out
in about five billion years
and so as one pundit put it i guess i'll
be cracking those passwords in the dark
so a very very strong password so
to answer that question you would have
something like uh he had mentioned
my password might be uh i my wife were
married in 1990 and have two kids
well first off your wife's not gonna let
you forget that okay second off
uh your kids aren't either you'll see
them every day
something easy for you to remember but
very
difficult for them to come up with
something personal to you
that is in a long string of characters
you have to enter just once
and then the rest of the passwords are
put in for you at the various sites that
you go to
all right that's the best scenario all
right and
absolutely the best that's great i've
heard of lastpass before i was actually
going to recommend it to my
mother-in-law again as i say
she's an elderly woman she has a million
different banking passwords and things
to remember and she has them all written
down somewhere on a sheet of paper that
she constantly loses
so something like this might be great
but i wasn't sure how secure is lastpass
right i mean what happens if somebody
breaks into lastpass and gets the
database of all those things i presume
that it's gonna be
it wouldn't matter that's good to know i
really appreciate that
all right uh this has been fascinating
and i could continue talking about it
with you forever
uh but we we are well past our time now
we got a late start and now we've run
late so i think we've we've
fulfilled our our obligation to
everybody i
really really appreciate uh you being
here tim it's pleasure to meet you and
to
to spend some time with you today i
apologize for the late start
oh don't worry about it uh technical
things happen with go to webinar it's
uh it's great once it works but uh it
can be a little buggy so it's not the
first time it won't be the last time
and to all of our attendees who joined
us today
we had a great turnout some terrific
questions
michael is saying thank you andrew is
saying thank you
we we wish we could get to all the
questions we just don't have time
but everybody took time out of their day
to join us here we really appreciate it
uh again take a look at the other
webinars that are coming up on simply
learn
join as many as you can get as much out
of it as you possibly can
uh thank you everybody for being here
we're going to go ahead and shut things
down and send you back to your
to your lives uh have a terrific rest of
your morning afternoon or evening
wherever you are
uh and oh one real quick thing if you
were one of those folks that was
interested we had a few
if you were one of those folks that was
interested in having someone contact you
i'm going to give you about 30 seconds
if you want to
to speed up the process throw your phone
number into the
question module nobody else will see it
but we'll have it
and that'll make it easier for somebody
to get back to you really quickly
and give you some guidance on helping
you pick out the right course so
i'll give you about 20 or 30 seconds to
throw your phone number in if you want
to and then we'll shut down
uh tim uh are you cued up for another
future webinar with us soon that we
should uh
point folks to i'm not i'm not sure at
this point
the date of it is but uh just be on
lookout for it i'm sure that i'll be
doing some more
exactly terrific uh okay thank you folks
i see a few people put their phone
numbers in there we appreciate that
we'll have someone get in touch with you
all right we'll take off now everybody
have a great day tim you have a great
day and everybody we will talk to you
all next time
take care everybody
you